Hi!
Many people have participated in the
daily community questions we have
on our YouTube community tab. And one thing
was appearing over and over and over again:
Well, if only there was someone
bored enough to help with that,
to create videos around these Machine Learning
Quiz Questions we are posting over there...
Hi there, my name is Tim, and
I'm currently doing my PhD on
Machine Learning mostly centered
around geometric and medical data.
First of all, please note that this
video is most likely not 100% correct,
perfectly accurate, or in any other way
beyond doubt or different interpretation.
If you find something that you disagree with,
please DO argue with us in the comments.
Just as Letitia, I'm just
a PhD Student – not someone
who can even remotely claim to know everything.
Besides, I don't think someone like that
even exists, and even the BEST make mistakes.
And I'm FAR from the best.
So, Letitia put out a question about Eigenfaces:
While an eigen face can just be seen
as a weird german-english mixed word
(fun fact: we call mutant words "denglish" in
german), it's also a way of analyzing faces.
And while eigenfaces are some
more "classical" computer vision,
invented before the dominance of neural
networks, they're still pretty interesting:
The idea is to describe a given
face through a combination of fixed
components, to be more exact: a LINEAR
combination of some base face pieces.
So to get Letitia's face, you could re-combine
the face pieces from the learned
base to actually form her face.
So, how do you do that? For a
given input collection of faces,
you represent them as vectors. Then, you
compute a Principal Component Analysis
of this data – basically obtaining the
"most important" vectors that you need
to properly express the faces in the
collection as a linear combination.
So for our faces given as a set of vectors, here
just shown with two dimensions (because drawing
100,000 dimensions gets somewhat cumbersome) we
compute the covariance matrix, then compute the
first k eigenvectors that we can then use as
a basis to approximate any input face vector.
And this is why we call these base faces
the "eigenfaces" – because they are face
components computed from eigenvectors of
the covariance matrix of all the faces.
These Eigenfaces can then be used for
things like real-time face detection
while they are still somewhat fast and robust,
at least when you compare that to other
approaches that are not Deep Learning-based.
For the next question, I want to summarize
what domain adaptation is, and for clarity,
also what transfer learning is in
general is and how that differs.
While that is a bit of a fuzzy definition,
we can generally say that domain adaptation
happens when one solves the same task but
changes the kind of input the task requires.
For example, we train to detect dogs in an image
taken during the day, and after domain adaptation,
we still try to detect dogs, but perhaps
now with images taken during the night.
We just have a different, but still
related input data distribution.
This domain adaptation is part of
what is called Transfer learning.
For transfer learning, not only the domain can
change, but the task itself can also change.
We repurpose a model trained on one
task to be used on a different one.
So… "What [actually] changes during
domain adaptation between settings?"
Well… we just swap out the data distribution
of the input. And as you can already imagine,
the difference whether something is
just domain adaptation or already
learning a different task is
somewhat flimsy and up for debate.
Where is the line in all of this? Is detecting
dogs at night already a different task?
Is detecting cats so much different
that it's not just a different data
distribution, but essentially a new task?
[Causation]:
Let’s move on to another one,
which is trying to find out how you see one
of the latest trends in Machine Learning.
You were asked whether you believe that
causality will be "The next big thing™
in machine learning - and
roughly half of you thought so.
So, what is causality in ML
about, and why do we need it?
Well, machine learning is TERRIBLE
at knowing causal relationships:
For example, when it's raining, there
more people outside holding umbrellas.
Without more information, an
machine learning algorithm
looking at images could also come to think
using umbrellas actually causes it to rain.
The machine learning algorithm doesn't know how
our world works, it just detects patterns and
correlations, and not causal relationships. And
correlation is not enough to establish causality.
Well, how do humans overcome this? With trying
things out! Does it start pouring if you pull
out your umbrella while the sun is shining? Well,
no. It only causes people to stare at you weirdly,
but that is exactly the problem: this "trying
out", which is called an "intervention"
in this causality context, is something
generally machine learning doesn't do.
Machine Learning is not embodied and generally
cannot act to generate their own training data.
It just looks at data and
makes statistical predictions,
detects patterns - it doesn't try out
things to find causal relationships.
So, why is that even important? If we just
want to make some predictions on known data,
we're fine without causality. But as soon
as we want to use deeper understanding of
the domain and find truly invariant
features, like by suggesting actions,
we need to learn causal structures,
and not just statistical correlations.
We may not want our house robot of the future to
actually have to drop our favorite vase to find
out that dropping it causes it to break,
and not breaking it causes it to drop.
If you want to dive deeper into that topic,
we'll leave you a link to a great talk
in the description below and rather
leave the technical parts to the experts.
In case that was nothing new to you: what do
you think? Let us know in the comments whether,
after transformers being one of the latest
big trends, now causality is... ALL YOU NEED.
Letitia:I sincerely apologize for his behavior!
[Manifold Hypothesis]
And lastly, we have two questions
that are somewhat related:
First of all, Letitia wanted to know
what the manifold hypothesis actually is.
So, a manifold, for starters, is any topological
space where the surroundings of each point are
similar to the Euclidean space. More simply
put, it's a space where for every local point,
we can describe it's neighburhood through a
chart, which is just a flat representation.
For example, for a sphere like the earth or a
coffee mug, if we zoom in enough, we have a flat
surface that we can create a map for; we can no
longer see the curvature. So this is a manifold!
Now the manifold hypothesis actually states
that complex data from the real world,
like photos or handwritten digits – that is,
high dimensional data with lots of pixels – can
be compressed into a lower dimensional form.
What that means is that for these 28-by-28
pixel wide hand written digits, we can express
all plausible hand written digits through far
less values than these 28-by-28 color values.
For example, we could reduce that to some
information on what handwritten digit it is,
and some piece of information that describes
how thick and skewed and so on this number is.
In result, we'd get a representation
that's probably a lot lower dimensional
than these 784 dimensions of our pixel space.
So, we then have a low dimensional representation
of our data that lies in the high dimensional
image space. This lower dimensional
structure, this more simple representation,
that is the data manifold.
And what happens to the rest
of the high dimensional space?
Well, it is populated with data that
does not make sense in the real world.
In the image space, this would consist of all the
images that are pure noise in all configurations.
In other words, the manifold hypothesis tells us
that natural data is more structured
and constrained than one would expect:
that the possibilities to generate implausible,
non-existent data points are far more numerous
than natural data which has a
certain simplicity attached to it.
So to summarize: the manifold hypothesis
just states that real world data, like these
handwritten digits, is actually lower-dimensional
than the original real-world space it lives in;
here the 784 pixel values. The same of
course holds for more complex examples,
like for pictures of cats or
representations of geometry.
[Denoising Autoencoder]
A question tightly linked to the manifold
hypothesis is on what a denoising autoencoder
actually does. For a denoising autoencoder, you
train an autoencoder on some data, that is, you
feed data through a neural network that at some
point has a smaller capacity than the input and
try to keep as much information alive as possible.
Now this should already sound
familiar to the manifold
hypothesis: an autoencoder with
a small bottleneck learns a lower
dimensional representation of the input data.
A noisy autoencoder then gets an
input that is actually corrupted,
for example, for handwritten digits, we
apply some noise to the image pixels.
When we then encode- and decode that and
now train such that the autoencoder does
reconstruct the input, this is removing
some part of the noise, because for the
high-dimensional input of the image, only the
lower dimensional part with actual meaning,
the part without the noise, the real
data manifold, is actually learned.
And that is because it is just way more
complicated to learn random noise patterns
rather than meaningful data,
and it is much more complicated to
fit that through the tiny bottleneck.
informally speaking, what this
actually does for our example,
is to learn the manifold of plausible
handwritten digits here inside the bottleneck.
For a noisy input that is not on that manifold,
the encoding process then just projects that
back onto the learned manifold, because that is
all that the autoencoder can actually memorize.
And by then decoding that,
we get a less noisy output.
There's some great and easy to
understand paper in the description below
with soome more thoughts about
the manifold, go check it out.
We hope this was somewhat interesting to you,
and I'd love to get some feedback and
some discussions below in the comments.
You can also suggest new community questions in
the comments so that these become
a bit more diverse in the future.
Thanks you very much for watching
and see you in another video!
Hopefully. Thanks, Tim!